allah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're new to my channel which most
of you probably are because it's my
first video my name is fayad and you
probably recognize me from the three
muslims podcast which we started a year
ago
now the whole point of me making this
video is because i used to travel the
world and i loved traveling traveling
was one of my escapes you could call it
from life the day-to-day
responsibilities that i had it dawned
upon me after you know restrictions
started settling down a bit that i want
to travel i could go to turkey i could
go to greece i could go to all these
places that i wanted to go now i felt
this pull to do umrah
randomly right a lot of people say that
you almost get invited right and i
realized okay why not go to saudi but
not just that why not take my parents
with me see in islam parents are very
important we got to take care of them we
got to look after them we got to make
sure that we can repay what they did to
us but not just that for the sake of
allah i just want to quickly mention
before we get right into it that i will
be posting a lot of vlogs on this
channel so i have a dubai vlog coming
next week with uh gabriel al romani i'm
also going to have a full makkah and
medina vlog separately i'm also going to
have a full guide to doing umrah with
the pandemic with all the restrictions
the qr codes the apps how to navigate
through how to maneuver through it how
to make it simple that's all going to
come so make sure you subscribe to the
channel and turn on post notifications
and let's go on with the journey
all right bro
let me
mashallah see you soon
foreign
medina was
a beautiful city mashallah i would even
say i personally vibed with medina at
least the city more than makkah the food
the vibe the atmosphere everything was
rich now i really did like the masjid
when i went to majjadan navari it was it
was miraculous mashallah like this was a
completely life-changing experience
seeing where the prophet saws was you
know buried and just seeing where all
the sahaba were and and what a what a
monumentous place i must say
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
now as the days were going by i realized
that okay you know it's time for makkah
soon it's time for amra you know
everything's legitimizing now that you
know my time in medina was almost over
but i was ready nonetheless and
let's go over to makkah
assalamualaikum
uh
[Music]
the drive to makkah wasn't so bad it was
about four ish five-ish hours maybe six
ish with some stops we stopped to uh get
into the state of irham but a lot of
people that you know these terms are
near familiar i might even make a video
if you guys want about like a simple how
to perform umrah but essentially to
perform
there are four steps number one is
basically
a garment but it's also a state it's
also a condition that you're in being in
the state of irham is separate from the
garment i just want to clarify that
garment is just a two-piece
towel-looking you know garment that men
wear
but the state of iran a lot of things
that are permissible or halal become
impermissible right so things like
intimacy uh quarreling arguing idle talk
these things are you know we shouldn't
do these things in the haram so that's
the first thing the second thing is
doing tawaf the tawaf is circling around
the ka'ba seven times
uh pretty simple and once that's done we
go to the third thing which is saee
going between safa and marwa uh seven
times it's about three four kilometers
so a little longer than doing tawaf and
the fourth thing is shaving your head so
for men we shave our head
and it's a sunnah to do so we can take
off like an inch or two if we have long
hair um but we got to do that to exit
ahem and for women it's just you know
they're not allowed to shave their head
so women sisters they take off a little
bit of their hair like cut like an inch
or so
oh
[Applause]
now when i first saw the kaaba for the
first time in my life
all those instagram moments all those
youtube vlogs that i've been seeing it
hits different it's not like any other
place in the world for a complete moment
in time nothing else matters
you know all my assignments
med school family nothing matters donya
making money nothing else matters
everything is at a standstill
and the world is is just static for a
glimpse
for a moment in time
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
rashford
[Music]
come on
if you have money and you like traveling
then you gotta go perform umrah and hajj
at least once in your life there's
there's no excuse
like if you if you're thinking of
traveling you know it's good weather
where you're at or if it's winter where
you're at right now it is where i'm in
canada and you want a little escape then
go to perform umrah go for a purpose
don't just be traveling idle now i've
been doing that and i'm speaking from
experience that
going somewhere with a purpose in mind
is completely revolutionary compared to
just going to iceland for the sake of
i've done that i really do recommend
that but at the same time go perform
amra
[Music]
foreign
now once we were done you know
doing umrah
it dawned on me that you know jabal
al-nude which is the the mountain where
hira is at the cave where prophet saws
first received revelation from jibrilla
i realized that you know this is
something that we didn't do yet and we
might want to do
but it's also something tough you know
40 50 degree weather it's like a four or
five hour hike round trip it's tough
it's very it's very hot um steps aren't
really too consolidated and you know
there's not like a lot of people there
not many people speak english however me
and my mom we made this happen
my mom and i we went to like the base of
the of the mount you know jablon no and
we were realizing okay let's just scout
it out look at it maybe we'll consider
it but
subhanallah somehow we just made it up
we started taking some steps and this
whole trip this whole uphill journey was
all spiritual there was no mental or
physical energy that we expended yes we
felt tired but the main driving force
was your iman and once we made it to the
top it was much it was a beautiful view
and uh yeah let's go
foreign
this is where the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
first got revelation
almost up
and guys take this in
he
saw him did not have
stairs
you know
probably didn't have these water bottles
look at this so tough i saw a man old
man old pakistani uncle bro maybe 60 70
80 years old 85 years old
carrying a crate of water bottles
that he's going to sell and make some
money and people can give him sadoka
like
it just shows you how weak we are
in comparison to this prophet saw some
and how strong we think we are
when we can't even do this in the 21st
century without complaining
or at least i can't can
subhanallah
almost there
look at this view
allah
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now once this trip was done everything
was phenomenal food was good vibe was
good my iman is just 10 times higher
and that's an understatement by the way
a million times higher and everything
that i was struggling with going into
omra any any thing i was uncertain about
any doubt i had that's gone um and
anything that i
any and any good trait i have
masha'allah is not like a million times
as
strong right so i really do recommend
that if you guys do get the opportunity
you know time is now time is running out
clock is ticking you know you're not
getting younger as the days go by take
your parents take your family take your
wife take your wives and make this trip
happen and before you go make sure you
hit the subscribe button and smash the
like button subscribe turn the post
notifications on dubai vlog with gabriel
romani coming out next week
a lot of other vlogs are going to be
coming if you guys want me to do a full
guide how to perform almara and how to
navigate and go to saudi and make the
actual logistical side of the trip go
smooth then comment down below i'll
probably make that happen too and thank
you all for watching
i think in the 21st century a lot of
people are
too
dunya centric
and what do you mean by dunya centric
like everything is about the world life
cars phones
so
allah created us from this earth
he says in the quran from it we create
you and to it you'll return and from it
you will be resurrected against